uh we just learned the uh
the handwork okay so i'm gonna go
here
[Music]
short grip
start like this
you're gonna start with him turn okay
he'll start
across this disposal
okay let's try it
now you're going to want to tweak this
but there's no strength there
pull out
that's not what we're doing okay so if
you pay attention
when when you turn his arm
it makes the elbow go down
okay um so
i'm not going to turn it this way though
you can kind of do the same thing if you
keep going
and then like that
which is how you do cutting comments
so think more uh
and then i've turned his elbow down
not torque it down now
you find his his body his body
you see how he can move his leg i'm not
torquing his arm
i mean his body
his pulse is here and my knuckle of my
index finger
you find his body in his in his arm
it's like you don't need the knuckle you
see that okay
find his body turn the elbow down
don't crank the elbow down here
find his body so you see ikey adhesion
so now you're just doing it with the
grip
if you feel it in your knuckle you're
doing it wrong
okay what what the knuckle does is
though he can't he can't uh
twist he gets into that knuckle
just like uh
right he uh
it reduces angles that he has so then i
can get into his body
so the same thing it again you don't
need
you don't need that but it reduces
angles that he can do so
that's what that's for but it's all in
his body
[Music]
and then bringing that down and then
you're doing the same thing
with your grip in his body
if you try to do it here like you could
tell that elbows
so what i did in his body
and control the elbow when you focus
just on hurting him
you don't control the elbow so just like
the sword is pretty
comfortable grip but it's in his body
and when you feel the pressure on the
knuckle do you see
okay that's when you change
the pastor on it's telling you you want
to find zero pressure
so when i feel it then that's not the
right angle
you see go back to zero
don't you if you're strong enough you're
gonna like it
you're gonna feel your power but if you
feel your power you're not powerful
okay you don't need you don't need that
of course if you resist just like nicole
mikio
it hurt that knuckle gets you okay
but in his body in his body
bought
so if that's what's happening it sounds
kind of irrelevant
don't make something weird out of it
okay
so for example if you bend it you
actually
make this more
padded and you lose control of the
knuckle
so you see how your skin is
so leave it straight
if you want to do anything with that
hand
make his hand stay straight okay
don't let him curl you keep his hands
straight
you see okay don't curl it
all right
so i'm in your ball you see
nothing is not in here okay it's going
in your body
okay so i don't go here
you see how you always do that it goes
in your body
in
do you
[Music]
[Applause]
you're even strong enough to stop me
from doing it you're saying you can't do
it
why are getting your body
these are sacred
see that difference okay
when the people have bigger forearms you
see look look at this is the joke
you see okay my finger is barely on the
other side you can see
but just like you see
i don't even need to be on the other
side so they're safe in here
[Music]
i get in your body in your body
in your body here don't don't get
gluttonous you see stay in the butt
even at the beginning no but okay i'm in
the body then i
got it it's not no i don't you see it's
starting to fall apart here okay
you see stay in the bottom same thing
here don't look
at it no it's falling apart stay in the
body
okay so if i
am doing um
right i can it's not a
kind of elbow toward me
is that through this contact point
i'm in this image
it's not do you see that
i'm
which is why he can open his grip
don't even hook you see and i can
do the same thing and it's why
i don't i could do the same
you see
going to this technique
i can do the same
hence it's not a matter of grip
or grip dependency the technique that is
grip dependent
is not martial it will not work
even people that are weaker than you
can with better footing out leverage you
okay and it's a lot to ask that you
always stronger than whoever
you're engaged with
so you say his album
it's on this side it will always fail
if you try to do this you see this all
the time on your heel
the guy's elbows like that yeah
that's not gonna work okay so
even with his elbow down it doesn't
matter
it can still be in his hand it doesn't
his his elbow's down right it does
it doesn't matter wherever you want to
be you can still
move his center so his elbows down
don't don't crank here make his elbow
up you see
so as you're going and we're all nice
and starting from this
neutral position please
don't do something that's going to make
his elbow go there
because that what you did to do that
made this
totally not work okay so move his body
move his body
so you start here you go like this
you make the elbows behind me now you
see just in your
forcing it keep the contact
move his body move his body
then even if his elbow gets like that
you know you can't move his body from
here
you see whatever he touches you you can
move his body
so it's weird because when you when you
force this and you make the elbow
it's your worst nightmare but when
you're doing it right
it didn't it doesn't matter where his
elbow is do you understand it's like
that's the universe for you okay
so usually you can see that because
you're torquing like that
okay but i want to understand that what
you're trying to
stop from happening is the more you
torque is the more
that elbow gets back there but if you
did it right it wouldn't matter that
this
is not his center in there yes it is
it is in there and it will work okay
so really try not to
because that doesn't work it's
mechanically inferior
there's also no kazushi if you pay
attention you see
move his body move his body
[Music]
he throws the other strike his body is
moving
you go like this throws the other strike
man always
always the posture okay so try it again
and use the you be honest with yourself
it's mechanically at its ceiling
why because you are mechanically using
it
okay so uh so far the armpits that you
have you control the elbow
the elbow is always a key point for
control
especially on the outside though
you can control the shoulder and you can
control the hand by controlling the
elbow
while i control the wrist i don't really
control the elbow i'm using
i control the wrist i don't really
control the shoulder too much
unless while i contact here
i'm not just go well he said move his
center
energy has to go into the elbow
and energy is going into his elbow
into itself so when i do this
uh it has to go there so in other words
i'm not going like this see that
so some of you get like he's tilted and
then you go like that it's not in the
elbow anymore
but at the same time the elbow must be
connected to the center
in other words if i go on like this
that's not in his body do you see so
somewhere you are
torquing the arm just there
so it is through the elbow to the center
through the elbow no do you think
through the elbow in the center
oh what are some clues that you have is
that his body move
his bot his body is moving his body
moves
body blues the whole time uh
when when you're just in the elbow his
body is there even if i was strong
enough his body didn't move do you see
so like the big men can tweet the small
women's arms but their center's not
moving
okay and then they'll punch you they'll
stab you
and you don't have the skill of
connection
so see this
maybe i maybe maybe i shrink it you see
but the principle is still the same his
body has to move
okay i say same example here
so i'm not making his arm swing
energy has to go in into his body and
then his body has to move
okay got it so watch for these two
errors
is it's all in the elbow for those of
you that are strong enough like i'm not
strong enough to do it on him
okay or uh
the other one is that you're not in his
elbow at all and you're just moving his
body
you get it okay let's go all right
a beginner mistake aside from what we've
been talking about
is you're like well i need to control
the elbow so now you start doing it up
here
you're seeing you're up by the elbow uh
but the mod is going to be different and
then the opening for the technique isn't
quite segmented what was up by the elbow
what technique should i do
see on this one i'm not up by the bubble
i'm further outside
okay so again remember this pinky goes
on the wrist bones
okay and i have to have the skill
a fro from what wherever i'm touching
however i'm touching i have to be able
to find his
his center okay um
right all where wherever we're at
it does whatever it is whatever it is
right
have to be able to do it okay even as
he absorbs do you see he absorbs
i still have to be able to find his
center okay
so um
don't change it don't go to the obvious
down here
okay and then this has to find his
center no
no find his center find his center
it changes every time so some of you are
going like that
you see you have to find his center and
then some of you when you get over here
and you go to turn it
you leave his body and you're just in
the arm you see
so if you it's fine to turn it you do
want to turn it but
you want to turn it in a way that it's
affecting his center
okay but not at the elbow
down here okay let's try it okay so this
time
we're gonna we're gonna find the
movement
[Music]
now we're you're still getting a rep on
that other thing
okay but uh this time
we're gonna find the transition
okay but as i do the transition
i can't come out of his body okay
so you see this is not in his body so i
find it's in his body
it's in his body and it stays in his
mind
so in a way in a way
do you think he runs into the the other
young
hand it's very similar to uh
he he goes to push and he runs into the
ground he runs into the same thing
so it's not that i'm going here
why'd i start over and then i go
that's not what's happening okay so i'm
sending energy into that do you see how
that's happening
so in his body on his body
and that ground that grounding is what
i'm doing now i just do it with the grip
okay so the same same grip
see
[Music]
the more that i go here and then
this is not you could because we started
checking
you you could go like that i got his
body again you could but that
let's not do that let's transfer
the cookie into the other half okay
so body more sorry body
movement but keep it in his body
the body
body okay
let's so uh
you go here right
and then it's not that i keep taking
them down on that same line
is that i take i take this energy
and throw it back at me let's go in here
back at me and that's where this hand
comes in
do you see so the the technique has a
beat in it
it's not down down down down down down
there's a beat there
do you see it so i trade in which
is
don't forget your basics so
he has he has to do the kazushi pattern
so this is the inward the front inward
got it but then i'm going to change it
because i'm going to
do a pin so i'm going to create a zone
of sanctuary with a cross lateral check
on the
homologous so he can't be standing he
can't be like that
he can't beat this way okay
so this this arm
you recognize okay and we're going to
show it a little different
okay so he's going this arm is going to
go like
this now
so if you pay attention now
you're recognizing io if this
hand keeps going that way you're going
to stay in equal
this hand has to come back
this way
so as you pay attention
right pressure actually increases
right then do you see do you feel that
all right so it's not here
pressure's going off this hand
has to come back
and
so again this hand don't go here that
would be in the elbow
this pressure is now going to
push okay
oh now i don't just do it with the other
heart
you see that this handstand but this
hand has to bring it in
so if you pay attention this hand is
going to come
back not keep going into
you you have like let me forget oh he's
almost down
i but he's not down you're gonna he's
gonna come back up on me
so keep the kazushi going whoa
what's it coming back to
again if you watch the center it moves
twice
the center is moving then it's not that
it stays there
it's gonna move again
okay because we need position you're
painting the
ending again okay this i'm not gonna do
the technique i just want you to see the
there's projection capacity everywhere
you see at every uh degree
of the radius you can project project
okay now so even though i'm going
back you see the arms going back towards
me it still
projects you get it so
i'm over here like this and this hand
is not going to do the obvious and pull
this down
this this is basically going to project
on into this boom
so these are different patterns that
you're doing you're doing this
okay and this pattern is here
can you see that difference so you gotta
come
one boom and boom
so let's just try that one
okay don't get goodness come back around
and push
on don't
keep the pressure come around it and
then
push again
so it's what does that look like to you
all let's just our spiral okay
a warm pressure
you're gonna go here around
again okay try just that can see so
when you don't have cool q skills
then it's always push-pull and you can't
understand
how these geometries are actually
working okay
uh and then if he resists because you're
pushing and pulling he resists and the
technique doesn't work
but if he if he resists he's he's gonna
push
and he's gonna go further out okay
so um let's move on though okay
so uh we're gonna bring in the other
hand so
same drill what my other hand is here
okay and the other hand is doing the
same
helping okay the reason i took that hand
off
is because you're gonna become dependent
on the elbow
and then you're back here you see he's
just hanging out there
so again but it didn't matter that i was
in the other hand
or not so this hand is still doing the
same thing
the two hands are still doing the same
thing okay
[Music]
so you you now start to be in
this thing you see as opposed to
me and his uh body even though i'm
touching his elbow
i'm still in his body do you see
i'm not doing this stuff
okay so it's still in his body
okay don't fall from level
at the elbow and wrist joint okay
all right we're doing a technique from
here because uh
you just start cheating the more
elements you have elements you have okay
so uh but now what i'm going to do
is the same pattern
but my body into
and we just do the first cdb step okay
so in the body you can see this is the
body
it stays in the body you see so if you
see the projection you see in the body
and i move my body in there
and then don't tweak his arm his center
i was in his center you see and i stay
in his center
[Music]
in his center in his center in his
center
and well my goal is from goal one
don't be grip dependent okay i'm i'm not
i'm not turkey
[Music]
you can open your brick you see
where do i step so my hands stay on my
center
you see see where my hands are again
instead of doing my arms like i was in
the basic
my body does it
body
body my arms don't really move my body
moves
remember in the in the technique my arms
were moving
you see that
body
okay try it again
[Music]
okay not here
yeah it's always percussive
all right
see that see how it got all mushy okay
so what you have to do
is in the position
do you see that's where that projection
is
right here into the shoulders hi
what i have to do is get my
body inside of it
see i have to be inside of it
when i have that so i mean here when i
do that
but i do that with this
you gotta take that step okay okay try
it two more times each